marraine
ensemble nous avons fondé l'Union
nordique
au printemps nous célèverons les
fiançailles du roi Eric mon fils et de
la princesse Philippa d'Angleterre nous
serons intouchables plus personne
n'osera nous faire la guerre Votre
Majesté je reviens directement de
grodens j'ai vu un homme là-bas le roi
Olaf mon fils
mon fils est mort il y a 15 ans
quelqu'un veut nous piéger il ne sait
pas qui l'a fait il le fera la reine
Malika seul fils mais et les rois Eric
elle l'a adopté il est de Poméranie
amenez-le moi ici je le verrai demain
monsieur puis-je vous demander votre nom
je suis le roi Olaf au cancer qui est
assis sur notre eau de mer qui es-tu
le seul roi que je reconnaisse est assis
là à sa place légitime sur ce trône
là-bas
nous n'allons pas prendre un homme sans
savoir qui il est vous avez dit
vous-même que ce n'était pas votre fils
tu lui as donné de belles funérailles
oui mais je n'ai jamais vu son corps
toi et Eric avait le soutien de tous les
royaumes du nord et de leur peuple vu
que tu risquer de le perdre si j'avais
amené un âne devant cette Cour vous
auriez certifié que c'était votre fils
nous sommes accusés par une mère qui ne
sait dire si un homme et son fils je
veux découvrir ce qui s'est passé le
jour où mon garçon nous a quitté yes
vous savez tout ce qui je suis
le roi
[Musique]
toute l'Europe nous observe je n'ai peur
de personne